[Music]
there's nothing more attractive than
confidence and Bayonetta three developer
Platinum Games is well aware of it from
the way Bayonetta saw Shays about the
screen left hand cocked on her hip while
the other clutches her gun to the sheer
bombastic nature of the game itself
every part of Bayonetta 3 is
unapologetically self-assured like the
titular witch baynetta 3 feels as if it
doesn't much care how it's perceived
because it knows its own worth as a game
that offers fast and fluid gameplay
jaw-dropping spectacles comedy and camp
in a way very few others do and it's
hard to argue with that when it's true
like its predecessors Bayonetta 3 is
spectacular in the truest sense of the
word though the game's core gameplay is
familiar it UPS the stakes sending
players on a multi-dimensional journey
across time to save the world if that's
not enough this Venture also comes with
full-scale Kaiju battles exhilarating
Chase sequence says a new sword-wielding
character who is wildly fun to play as
and a series of 2D stealth-based
chapters that follow Jean as she
infiltrates enemy headquarters all this
paired with the qualities that made
Bayonetta 2 so beloved make for a can't
miss entry in the action game genre
Bayonetta 3 begins with a bit more
breathing room than his predecessors but
just barely after introducing the
concept of a Multiverse filled with
other bayonettas other genres and the
gut sinking feeling that everything we
do has been done before it Dives head
first into action-packed gameplay as a
supernatural storm overtakes New York
City Bayonetta is forced to take on the
homunculi a new enemy that are neither
Angel nor demon and are hell-bent on
eradicating not only are bayonetta's
universe but every universe and every
version of Bayonetta imaginable
naturally it falls upon Bayonetta to put
a stop to these plans carrying over from
the previous games are the basic kick
punch and shoot abilities which can be
linked together to form complex and
Visually delightful combos as well as
both torture attacks and climaxes for
over-the-top flourishes
Bayonetta also still relies upon
perfectly timed Dodges to enter which
time a state in which all enemies are
slowed down to a near halt as Bayonetta
rips through their defenses with bullets
and beatdowns though performing Combos
and avoiding taking damage is still
vital to winning battles and earning
high-ranking medals fan out of three
pivots away from the previous game's
dependence on weaving together masterful
combos to fill your magic meter instead
allowing it to fill throughout combat in
order to charge up bayonetta's
show-stopping abilities two such
abilities are demon masquerade and Demon
slave the former of which allows
Bayonetta to take on the form of one of
her demons to utilize part of their
abilities the latter summons an infernal
demon you can control and battle through
risque dance this adds an interesting
bit of strategy to the action game as
you must ensure your dance is not
interrupted by an attack consider which
demon works best in each battle and
manage your magic meter to ensure that
you're ready to summon a demon when the
opportune time presents itself
thank you
at times controlling these demons can be
a bit chaotic particularly The Game's
new train demon wartran Guan which
requires you to place down tracks while
in battle before it emerges and dishes
out massive damage however once you slow
things down and get deliberate about
your movements they quickly become a
blast to use the same can also be said
about combat as a whole though Bayonetta
3 accommodates button Mashers it is
lightly punitive to such methods in a
way that encourages growth if you don't
make the time to learn how to properly
time your attacks Dodges and use of
abilities the game's increasing
difficulty will prove to be too much of
course you can grind levels and invest
in accessories healing items and items
that Grant you upgrades to your health
and magic bars that will sustain your
button mashing ways but Bayonetta 3
gives you all the tools you need to
learn and exceed the way it's intended
offering up visual cues that instruct
you to interact with Targets in unique
ways and other helpful tools however
this does not mean there's no room to
incorporate your own style oil in
Bayonetta 3 you can equip two weapons
each with their own unique kit of skills
and combos allowing for you to quickly
cycle between them in battle in fights
with large slow enemies using a tankier
weapon can help Bayonetta take them down
quickly conversely high-speed enemies
require high speed attacks lest you want
to spend the bulk of a fight chasing
them down and swinging at air other
weapons such as my personal favorite the
ignis irania yo-yo excel at keeping you
skyborne which is a helpful skill when
fighting enemies that deal close range
damage Bayonetta can also cycle through
three equipped infernal demons each with
their own fighting style though Malthus
might have a fair bit of dexterity
monstrosities like Gamora are powerful
yet slow all this makes for a game that
allows you to play how you want to play
which only adds to how powerful you feel
while doing it as well as the game's
overall replayability in addition to
standard battles Bayonetta 3 also boasts
stunning cinematic showdowns that
feature enemies of Staggering
proportions and culminate in are
dropping moments from swinging across
crumbling buildings as a sort of hellish
Spider Woman to entering spectacular
Kaiju fights complete with devastating
beam attacks the game is unpredictable
and relentlessly exciting this is all
made even better by the fact that
Bayonetta 3 ensures that the player
stays in control throughout most of
these sequences when they could have
just as easily cast the interaction
aside in favor of QuickTime events I
can't think of many action games that
feel as frenetic and fun as Bayonetta 3
or play with scale and framing to quite
the same effect Bayonetta 3 does a
fantastic job of honoring its titular
character with battles every bit as big
bold and beautiful as she is
outside of combat the game is similar to
previous entries and then it has light
open world sections where Bayonetta can
Traverse as she seeks out encounters
referred to in the game as verses the
environments range from Tokyo subway
stations and collapsing skyscrapers to
ancient ruins and historical landmarks
and feature hidden secrets challenges
and areas where time has been distorted
in each of these zones you play as a
young Bayonetta attempting to rewind or
fast forward time in order to solve a
puzzle and progress while not too
profoundly stylized or robust these
areas are enjoyable to search around
however even with all of these abilities
saving the world is a tall task for one
witch alone fortunately Bayonetta has
two powerful friends eager to lend her
helping hand the first of these is
longtime companion Jean who adds her own
unique flavor to the game in the shape
of 2D stealth challenges though they're
fairly short and simple these challenges
are a blast to play and add a sort of
camp be Katana zero vibe to the game a
genre versus floors silently takes down
enemies crawls through ducks and
stumbles into some humorous interactions
Bayonetta also finds help in a young and
mysterious Katana wielding woman named
Viola though Viola might project a devil
may care attitude as she trudges around
in her low-rise plaid pants knee-high
combat boots and distressed leather
jacket this newcomer is a bit of a softy
a fact Bayonetta has far too much fun
with however this doesn't mean Viola
isn't tough as Nails equipped with a
katana in her own infernal demon named
Cheshire Viola is a fast-paced blast to
play as while she uses the same core
mechanics as Bayonetta there are a few
key differences between the two firstly
you don't have to control Cheshire the
cat-like creature is confined in Viola's
blade meaning you simply throw the sword
and then bare knuckle brawl while he is
out you're also able to both block and
Dodge attacks as Viola though only
blocking at precisely the right moment
allows you to enter which time Viola
also carries herself quite differently
than the graceful contortionist we know
and love rather than perform delicate
acrobatic movements Viola moves like a
dextrous sword herdsmen shrouded by a
youthful energy that is almost
electrifying whereas bayonetta's
post-battle screen shows her arching
backwards with a knowing smile violas is
accompanied by a power chord and a punk
expression
the dynamic between these three witches
is both charming and chaotic and another
high point in a game full of them it
also reinforces one of the Bayonetta
series most interesting themes a woman
does not necessarily grow more powerful
the more masculine she is despite Viola
being a lot more of a tomboy than the
Slender and large busted Bayonetta it's
made very apparent that Bayonetta is an
artist with a gun and someone Viola can
learn a lot from on her journey of
growth Bayonetta 3 is a Leap Forward
from two particularly in terms of how
Bayonetta and the main party look and it
makes good use of the switch's hardware
capabilities unfortunately there are
noticeable deficiencies too and as newer
titles hit current gen consoles it
becomes increasingly clear that the
switch is struggling to keep up in the
case of Bayonetta 3 this results in
often Barren locations in NPCs that look
severely outdated the game does a lot to
ensure your eyes are focused on the
action where it looks vibrant with
colors and detailed with particle
effects however allow yourself to look
at the background and you'll be met with
simple geometry crude textures and dull
tones based on my playthrough this seems
to be a trade-off that Platinum games
has made to ensure the game runs well
regardless of if players are using a
switch in handheld mode or docked but
it's one that comes at a very visible
cost what Bayonetta 3 lacks in visual
Fidelity however it more than makes up
for with style with bright colors and a
jazzy feel to the game it Ventures
closer to atlas's prowess with Style the
music is also fantastic from dramatic
numbers filled with operatic vocals to
the fast-paced pop punk tunes that play
on viola is on the field the game does
not lack in tracks that are just as
Grand and energetic as Bayonetta 3
itself I'm not sure whether it's because
of the game's fantastic music the use of
the word verse to refer to encounters or
her over-the-top style but when I think
of Bayonetta I can't help but imagine
her as a pop star Bayonetta 3 feels like
her Las Vegas residency a lavish and
spectacular show where each number is
beautifully choreographed every song is
a banger and the guest appearances are
sure to Delight it's a fast paced and
joyous Adventure that achieves its goals
with an abundance of Charisma and style
while it might have taken the better
part of a decade to get here the queen
is back and she's ready to serve don't
worry I know this song by heart